so I cupped my ball and I walked to my
knees together to show the doubts from a
good family the guy goes hey man this
Ireland that happens all the time
shake it off kid walk with your dick out
welcome if this is not happening
I'm your host Roy Wood jr. hey there you
go boys drink up nobody's gonna remember
what the hell's happening tonight that
dudes trying to get my couch pregnant
he's peeing out the window come on man
John Legend bought me that piano
throw the ball pit
[Applause]
[Music]
I can make your transformation in my
life three years ago I don't know if you
can see the scar I have on my forehead
the lines you go like that of wrinkles
but this one is a scar I've been a heavy
drinker and a heavy party of my whole
life and three years ago I was so drunk
in Philadelphia I blacked out and fell
off of a barstool like a tree and busted
my head open on a tile floor and once my
head at the ground I was wide awake no
it's blood everywhere and some guy grabs
my arm and he lifts me up and he yells
out to the bar I wouldn't that I
don't have health insurance don't you
dare call an ambulance he goes you got
to get to a hospital I'm like how far is
the nearest hospital he goes two blocks
two blocks and you were gonna call an
ambulance that's like $15,000 man so I
got a wad of napkins off the bar and I
walked to the hospital and after I
walked that first block I said to myself
7,500
but I have not drank or done drugs in
three years everybody and I want you to
know I want you to know I want you to
know the way I used to feel about
cocaine is how I now feel about
doughnuts I mean I won't go out chasing
after it but if a friend's got a bag I
have a taste maple bar so I'm singing
about times in my life I was really
up five years ago I was in Galway
Ireland and I was so drunk I woke up in
the middle of the night in my hotel room
to go to the bathroom and I went into
the bathroom and the door closed behind
me but what it actually happened was I
was now in the hallway and I was locked
out of my room and I don't know if any
of you have ever been naked and drunk
and had to approach the front desk for
another key but I thought you should
show some humility you know so I cupped
my ball and I walked to my knees
together to show the dogs from a good
family
got to the front desk and the guy goes
hey man is Ireland that happens all the
time
shake it off kid walk with your dick out
be proud so I think the biggest blunder
that ever happened to me from drinking
was 15 years ago I was in Hong Kong
doing shows and I stayed at the
shangri-la hotel the nicest hotel I have
ever stayed at in my life beyond
five-star opulent luxury and I've never
been to Hong Kong before so the first
day I was there I just walked and walked
and soaked the city and with my eyeballs
and when I went back to my hotel room at
the end of the day dad put a goldfish
and a little goldfish bowl in my room
and there was a note next to it and it
said traveling is sacred but no one
deserves to be alone
that's why we provided this friend the
goldfish to keep you company during your
stay here two nights later Fat Boy slim
is doing a concert on the Kowloon side
of the harbour I love Fat Boy slim I got
tickets
the audience was the most beautiful
fashionable Chinese people they look
like they had fallen out of fashion
magazines and Fat Boy slim was
electrifying that night and I was just
dancing with all these beautiful people
and I got really really drunk that night
and somehow in the middle of the night
back in my hotel room I the bed I
was drunk and half asleep and I thought
it was a fart and I blew it out and this
wet ass penguin all over the bed
and I was ashamed man I had never a
bed before in my life really I felt
terrible about this so the next sale up
the hotel early without making eye
contact with the housekeeping staff and
I walked around all afternoon and I went
back to my hotel room at the end of the
day dad taking my goldfish away no one
deserves to be alone except for you you
creepy bad and weird up you know
it's funny about that is that story
happened to me 15 years ago and I did
not even tell my closest friends and I
damn sure wouldn't old our story on
stage cuz I was single before maybe I
wanted to meet a nice girl after the
show and do a little moon now married I
don't give a I a bed yeah
all over that you guys
are great thank you very much
[Applause]